let's say that Y is equal to log base
four of x squared plus X what is the
derivative of Y with respect to X going
to be equal to now you might recognize
immediately that this is a composite
function we're taking the log base four
not just of X but we're taking that of
another expression that involves X so we
could say we could say this thing in
blue that's U of X let me do that in
blue so this thing in blue that is U of
X U of X is equal to x squared plus X
it's going to be useful later on to know
what u prime of X is so that's going to
be just going to use the power rule here
so 2x plus 1 drawing that brought that 2
out front and decremented the exponent
derivative with respect to X of X is is
1 and we could say the log base 4 of
this stuff well we could call that a
function V we could say V of well if we
said V of X this would be log base 4 of
X and then we've shown in other videos
that V prime of X is going to be very
similar that if this was log base E or
natural log except we're going to scale
it so it's going to be 1 over 1 over log
base 4 sorry 1 over the natural log the
natural log of 4 times X if this was V
Evette if the V of X was just natural
log of X our derivative be 1 over X but
since its log base 4 and this comes
straight of the change of base formula
is that you might have seen and we have
a video where we show this but we just
scale it in the denominator with this
natural log of 4 or you could think of
scaling the whole expression by 1 over
the natural log of 4 but we can now use
this information because Y this Y can be
viewed as V of V of remember V is the
log base 4 of something but it's not V
of X we don't have just an X here we
have the whole expression that defines U
of X we have U of X right there and let
me draw a little line here so that we
don't get those two sides
confused and so we know from the chain
rule the derivative of Y with respect to
X this is going to be this is going to
be the derivative of V with respect to U
or we could call that V prime V prime of
U of X V prime of U of X let me do the U
of X in blue V prime of U of x times u
prime of X well what is V prime of U of
X we know what V prime of X is if we
want to do be prime of U of X we would
just replace wherever we see an X with
the U of X so this is going to be equal
to V prime of u at U of X and you just
use you're taking the derivative of the
green function with respect to the blue
function so it's going to be 1 over the
natural log of 4 natural log of 4 times
instead of putting an X there it would
be times U of x times U of X and of
course that whole thing times u prime of
X and so and I'm doing more steps just
hopefully so it's clear what I'm doing
here so this is 1 over the natural log
of 4 U of X is x squared plus X so x
squared plus X and we're going to
multiply that times u prime of X so
times 2x plus 1 and so we can just
rewrite this as 2x plus 1 over over over
the natural log of 4 natural log of 4
times x squared plus x times x squared
plus X and we're done we could
distribute this natural log of 4 if we
found that interesting but we have just
found the derivative of Y with respect
to X